good afternoon and welcome thank you for
joining us for this conversation about
defending democracy at home
I'm Kim Gough Cruz secretary and vice
president for student life and along
with my colleagues we are honored to
work with secretary Kerry and the Kerry
initiative to sponsor this and many
other important conversations the topic
defending democracy at home is very
special to us we are after all a
university that preceded the formation
of our American democracy by a full 75
years today we join other colleges and
universities to play an important role
in nurturing and sustaining our
democracy as Whitney Griswold the 16th
president of Yale said in 1953 the freer
the society the greater the
responsibilities it imposes upon the
individual citizen and the greater these
responsibilities the greater that
citizens need for the help of the
liberal arts yell prepares students for
lives of civic engagement public service
and meaningful leadership so that they
can fulfill their responsibilities as
citizens and we are expanding access to
higher education for students from all
backgrounds extending the reach in the
impact of a Yale education we are
engaging in conversations like this one
about how to involve more people in the
democratic process and deliver on the
promise of our national ideals I know
many Yale students and alumni like our
guests on stage today
are eager to tackle this critical work
so let's begin
our distinguished guests today are two
extraordinary yellow alumni miss Stacey
Abrams and the Honorable John Kerry mr.
Kerry as many of you know is Yale
College class of 1966 and he served as a
60s 68th US Secretary of State under
President Obama prior to that he
represented the great state of
Massachusetts our neighbor for over 25
years in the US Senate
he is also a decorated combat veteran
who soothed who served two tours of duty
in the Vietnam War we are proud that mr.
Kerry is a distinguished fellow at the
yells Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs and we are grateful for his
leadership of the Kerry initiative at
Yale the Kerry initiative brings
together scholars practitioners and
experts from diverse disciplines to
tackle critical global problems and
Stacey Abrams our other guests is no
stranger to tackling big problems a 1999
graduate of Yale Law School miss Abrams
served as Minority Leader in the Georgia
House of Representatives from 2011 to
2017
last year she became the first African
American woman nominated by a major
party in a governor's race in US history
this year she became the first
african-american woman to deliver a
response to the State of the Union
address she is at the forefront of
efforts to address voter suppression and
to strengthen the integrity of the
democratic process in this country today
miss Abrams received the Alumni
achievement award from Yale Law women
for fighting for the rights and voices
of women of working families and voters
of color so thank all of you for being
with us today and please join me in
giving a very well yell warm welcome to
Stacey Abrams and John Kerry
Roger
I wish you guys lived in Georgia well
welcome everybody obviously you are
thrilled as I am to have Stacey here and
we're very lucky to be able to share her
insights on one of the most important
issues that we face in America today
which is the fundamental right of our
fellow citizens to be able to vote when
I was an undergraduate here one of the
things we first became involved in in
that age of activism 1963 for was the
Mississippi voter registration drive and
we had leal students climbing on two
buses over on High Street and giving
them a send-off to go down to
Mississippi and help people to register
to vote it's dangerous obviously lives
were lost but what's what's most
extraordinary when I was running for
president I visited Birmingham and I
went to the normal civil rights sites
that are not normal at all they're quite
remarkable but what hit me of the
Southern Poverty Law Center was the
memorial with this fountain and this
dial and on the dial with water spilling
out over the dial were the names of all
of the people who were murdered trying
to vote it's quite extraordinary to
remember a time in my lifetime when you
were murdered on route to register or
after you had registered just trying to
exercise your right obviously
our Constitution wrote it into it
slavery before it wrote it out so this
has been a tortured journey for us as
Americans and I and and I think in the
last session that we just had with the
three secretaries of defense I was
reminded of the degree to which the
changes taking place now are also rooted
in purposeful exploitation of race and
of culture issues so what Stacey is
doing is really much more important than
many Americans have yet tuned into and
she's doing it obviously based on very
personal experience a rather remarkable
experience she wasn't just the first
african-american candidate first black
woman to be a nominee for president for
for governor
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just just a word to the wise it sounds
better than it is but that said that
said she did it in Georgia Georgia
imagine that it's a big deal and it was
a tough road I think everybody here one
of the reasons you're all standing up
and welcoming her so appropriately is
because you know what a big deal it was
but you also know how she handled
herself with extraordinary grace and and
energy and we're all better for that so
we have a lot to learn here in the next
minutes we'll all spend together we will
have a section at the very end towards
the end where we bite questions from all
of you actually that's a lie
from a few of you because in the spirit
of the new age of candor but really
privileged that Stacey saw fit to come
here she also was the first person the
first african-american woman from
elected official to give the State of
the Union response on behalf of our
party so I was tempted to say Stace what
you been up to but before I do I want to
introduce another good friend here if I
may he just took part in the session we
had on secretaries of defense so I've
given away he is a former secretary
defense he's also a former director of
the CIA former OMB budget director
former chairman the Budget Committee in
the House of Representatives where he
spent 16 years and former chief of staff
in the White House so would you welcome
with me Leon Panetta
[Music]
my thanks to the Jackson Institute my
thanks to all those at Yale who helped
us put on events
it's never easy and we're very
appreciative so let's get right to it
Stacy since you since the campaign
you've made it your purpose now to make
sure that Americans can vote and so
you've started two entities to do that
one is fair fight which is to make sure
our campaigns in fact are fair and
competitive and the other is fair count
which is to deal with the issue of
people's ability to be able to build by
virtue of being able to register by
virtue of being counted in the census
what are the questions that asked in
many ways it can be said that we have
our own modern-day poll tax we have our
own modern-day disenfranchisement in
2019 heading into 2020 53,000 people in
Georgia who did not have their votes
counted and we're delayed in being able
to take part in the campaign because of
anomalies in their registration that
were not necessarily anomalies at all
why don't you explain if you would what
is at stake here what are the challenges
that you see him how did people sitting
here how do all of us begin to make a
difference thank you first of all
secretary Kerry thank you for having me
thank you to Secretary Panetta secretary
Albright everyone here thank you
can can we stop for a minute binary
migrate brooch wearing remarkable
secretary of state first woman ever to
be Secretary of State ladies and
gentlemen Madeleine
[Applause]
I truly assumed she was in the earlier
panel I apologize that shows you how
focused I'm just I'm kind of starstruck
so high so for me this has been you know
the only thing I've known for a very
long time my parents were very involved
in the civil rights movement in
Mississippi I was raised in Mississippi
then moved to Georgia when I was a
teenager and when I was matriculating
through Spelman College when I was at
the University of Texas without you can
clap for Spelman it's good when I came
to Yale I've always been engaged in the
question of access I am driven to do the
work I do because I believe poverty is
immoral I think it's economically
inefficient I think it's a waste of
human capital and I think it's solvable
but no one will solve it until those who
are most affected by it have a voice in
the solution so that's sort of my macro
frame back in 2014 I'd served as
Democratic leader in the house starting
2010 and in 2013 I was helping people
signed up for the Affordable Care Act
and through the work we were doing
realized that there were 800,000
unregistered people of color in the
state of Georgia 600,000 of whom were
African American and that elections in
Georgia were largely swung by about
250,000 votes and so my first foray into
aggressive voting rights changes was to
get this group registered and that was
my first interaction with Brian Kemp who
was a Secretary of State and when I
registered 86,000 people we secure
registrations from 86,000 people over
the course of a four month period in all
159 counties he refused to process
40,000 of our applications
he swore they didn't exist we knew he
was lying because we had copies of them
because I didn't trust him so we kept
paper copies of everything and we
actually delivered them to his office
and I tell the story because that was
the first moment where I had true
understanding of what we were facing in
the body of Brian Kemp but more largely
written how far from the election was
that so this was in 2014 and it was we
did a registration project from March to
August and we were fighting him up until
Election Day and part of the challenge
was he first swore they didn't exist and
then he accused me of fraud because
under Georgia law if you receive an
application from any person you have to
turn it in because you don't want people
cherry-picking who gets to submit an
application so even if the person hands
you back the application that says that
this person is Mickey J Mouse on one two
three unicorn Lane the law says you have
to turn it in well we flagged those and
we knew that these were not lawful but
Georgia law says you have to turn it in
well he then used that to accuse me of
fraud we pushed back which is something
he hadn't faced before he'd been doing
this for the last few years two
different organizations who were
registering communities of color but I
happen to be the Democratic leader and I
kind of know the law and so
when he when he accused me of fraud and
subpoenaed me I sued him but we went
through state court the first time in
the state court our writ of mandamus was
thrown out because what we were asking
was for the court to force him to
process these 40,000 unprocessed
registrations and what the court said is
under Georgia law there is no
requirement for timely registration
meaning if you turn your application in
nothing in Georgia law says you have to
be processed by the election that you
were registering for so that's the first
flaw and indeed he did not process them
until after the election January the
following year he quietly processed
18,000 of them we had new 18,000 people
who all missed the election but finally
got on the rolls but we knew that
there's still an anomaly with more than
you know 25,000 applications and as we
investigated we discovered that he was
using a system called exact match where
your name on your application had to
exactly match either the Social Security
Administration database or the DMV
because neither of those places ever
make mistakes and when we took this to a
federal court a federal judge by the end
of 2016 said that it was racially
discriminatory on his face and he signed
a consent decree saying he would not use
that system any longer fast forward to
the beginning of 2017 and his first
stirrings of wanting to run for governor
he reimpose the system by getting the
Republican state legislature to pass a
state version of exact match and it was
that law that he used to disenfranchise
53,000 people whose applications were
dismissed for incredibly banal reasons
so for example a young man named del
Rios his last name is Del Rio's de el
space Rios in Georgia the DMV will not
print spaces between your first between
your last name if you have a space in
your last name they will not print it so
when he submitted his application it got
rejected for lack of exact match because
he spells his last name de el space Rios
and he has no reason to know that in
Georgia they won't put this
Aysen but the worst part is no one tells
you that's the problem
you just get a note back saying that you
cannot be processed and to resubmit
well you resubmit with the name Godin
and your parents gave you and you keep
getting rejected this happened to 53,000
people 90% of whom were people of color
70% of whom were african-american and
more than half were women what
percentage of the vote did that
represent so 53,000 would be about 1100
fewer than the number I lost by and I'm
not saying all these people would have
voted for me but you had 53,000 people
who were never even able to cast a
ballot now he says that they were
pending meaning they could go and try
but you had to convince a volunteer
worker on the busiest day of the year
to essentially over overrule what the
Secretary of State's office has said but
that's only one part of the problem and
in that and I will wrap it up in this
way voter suppression is not a single
instance I don't believe that those
53,000 people are purely representative
of the problem they are an example
because wrote a registration has three
pieces its registration access that's
being able to get on the rolls which is
what I'm talking about
which we try to address through voter
registration through the new Georgia
project which is the organization I
created in 14 voter registration is
first then it's staying then it's
getting processed which is the exact
match system then it's staying on the
rolls which is the use it or lose it
laws and if you know if you know what
happened in Ohio those are the laws that
say if you don't vote in a certain
number of years we have the right to
strip you of your ability to vote not
because you're dead not because you move
but because we think you should have
done it even though voting is not
mandatory in the United States millions
of people get purged for that reason and
Georgia
we know that 1.5 million people were
purged hundreds of thousands of whom
were purged not because they were not
living not because they were not
interested but because the last time
they voted was 2008 or 2012 and he used
that as a predicate to remove them from
the rolls then the second piece is
ballot access so let's say you get
through the gauntlet of registration oh
and let's not forget voter IDs for
people who can't get them because
they're too expensive
to get hard to keep and you don't have
the money to pay for it you get to
ballot access ballot access is shutting
down polling places what they did in
Indiana when they removed a polling
place where there used to be 10 early
voting centers in Marion County they
shut it down and made it one and put it
on the outskirts of town where people
who didn't have cars couldn't get to
them and Georgia Brian Kemp oversaw the
closure of 214 polling places out of
3,000 if you are low-income person who
doesn't have access to transportation
and you live in one of the many counties
more than 100 counties without public
transit if you get home and try to go
and vote and discover that instead of
being it being a mile away it's now 10
miles away you can't vote so it's ballot
access is actually being able to do it
and then there were thousands of people
who applied excuse me who applied for
absentee ballots and their absentee
ballots never arrived this happened in
Georgia this happened in Florida it's
happened around the country then your
third piece is ballot counting otherwise
known as Florida that's when you finally
submit a ballot you try to go and vote
and in Georgia we had an with the
longest wait times for african-americans
in the country averaging up to four
hours in some parts of town we had
communities where they were only
allocated two or three machines and we I
kid you not we had one of the busiest
polling places where they forgot the
power chords for the machines people
waited four to five hours to vote if
they could wait in line because in
Georgia you you cannot lose your job for
taking time off to vote but you don't
get paid for it if you're working if
your shift worker who makes $12 an hour
you took an hour to get there for hours
in line you've now missed almost a day's
pay to try to vote and you have no
guarantee you're gonna make it inside so
you know thousands of people got out of
line and went home or went back to work
because they simply couldn't afford to
vote that is a poll tax and then the
last was the actual absentee ballot well
and in the middle there is the pushing
the machines that we have where they
would flip the names a lot of people
voted for me and by
Kemp's name appeared on the screens and
then the last was the absentee ballot
counting which is that we had absentee
ballots that were rejected at
extraordinarily high rates the highest
rate of rejection was in the county in
Georgia that has the highest number of
naturalized citizens and actually nearly
flipped a congressional seat across the
state they use what's called signature
match meaning that the signature on the
back of your absentee ballot had to
match the signature that you used to
sign your voter registration card or
your ID my signature does not match from
Kroger to CVS and yet this mismatch was
used to justify the rejection of
thousands of votes and so our argument
is that individually each of these may
have some legitimate purpose but when
yoked together registration access
ballot access and ballot counting we now
have a de facto disenfranchisement of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of voters which means there is no
fundamental guaranteed right to vote in
the state of Georgia and I would argue
that this is playing out across the
country I just happen to be very
familiar with what happened to me in
Georgia so that's better suppression so
that's a great I mean that is a terrific
example and detailed obviously what can
happen I do not want to relitigate my
race for president but I will tell you
that in Ohio we had weights of 1215
hours we had to go to court to keep
lines move it to keep people able to
vote they voted two four or five in the
morning
particularly in Kenyon College and
machines in the morning when we started
getting telephone calls in Washington
telling us that people would go in and
push carry and it came up Bush we had
those machines taken out this is after
we had gone to court in Ohio to have a
verification by experts of the
legitimacy of the algorithm which was
running these machines
and we were denied that access based on
the proposition that it's proprietary
information private company private
company has the right to maintain the
secrecy of it and the private company
was owned by two brothers from Nebraska
who were both chairman of the Bush
campaign in Nebraska I mean it's quite
stunning
I said afterwards I said you know how
can it be then in the United States of
America the election of the President of
the United States of America is up to a
private company's legitimacy with
respect to its algorithm that nobody
gets to test since then we have found
not only were those machines hackable
but the machines today are hackable
absolutely and and that's been proven by
people have gotten in and you know you
can set an algorithm that takes every
4th vote and slices it off to the
opponent and then you can write the
algorithm in a way that at 8:00 o'clock
when the polls closed the entire thing
disappears so we're we're living in a
very fragile place with respect to our
hard democracy and I'm going to ask you
about that once you take it up a little
bit what's what's the meaning of this
now that we have and I hate to say it
I'm not here to be partisan and we're
gonna try very hard tomorrow in our
discussions just to be even-handed but
there is just a reality of a certain
truth there is one party in America that
goes out of its way to do all kinds of
things to prevent people from voting and
do engage in vote oppression and one of
those things is the possibility that
BOTS are working overtime run by the
Russians or some other country that
wants to impact the outcome of the
American election now that news became
public in your campaign and I think it's
worth you're you're so the extending the
degree to which problems arose as your
your opponent who was the sitting
Secretary of State responsible for
administering the election was the only
state in the country that refused to
accept D H Department of Homeland
Security oversight on making sure the
Russians didn't engage can you speak to
that so basically I ran against a
cartoon villain so he's the sitting
Secretary of State he is the in charge
of oversight of the process in November
sorry in 2017 before he put his name in
the ring to run for governor he oversaw
the purge of more than 300,000 people we
think it's up upwards of 600,000 he in
2016 when approached by the Department
of Homeland Security who identified a
number of states that were facing at
vulnerable systems that were subject to
hacking and to manipulation he is the
only secretary of state who refused the
support of the Department Department of
Homeland Security now Georgia had
systems that were basically being run by
Atari we have machines that were
purchased in 2002 you can no longer
upgrade our systems they are that old
and his response was that while
nothing's wrong even though this is the
same person who two days before the
election accused the Democratic Party of
somehow hacking the machines he was in
charge of and we found out later that it
was because he and his team had
mismanaged once again the process and
they had been hacked they just didn't
want anyone to know it was their fault
so they blame Democrats work I say all
that to say this the fragility of our
democracy is not in the ideal it's in
the execution and yet we have had a
party in the Republican Party and I am
partisan
who who have made it their mission to
diminish the trustworthiness of our
process and we see that in all of the
ways they put in place impediments and
peddle falsehoods to seem like truth but
fundamentally what is happening is they
are squeezing out communities from being
able to participate in democracy and you
see this in what happened in North
Dakota the requirement that Native
Americans living on reservations which
are still a stain on our American ideal
being told they have to have residential
addresses when we know that does not
exist and with a timetable that made it
impossible to solve that problem we know
that in states across this country we
have seen restrictions and in fact in
North Carolina they announced their
intention was to diminish the validity
in the capacity of African Americans to
cast votes regardless of what you want
in terms of power what worries me is the
erosion of our trust in our democracy
because democracy is a theory it only
it's only made real when people can
participate in it and believe it is so
and when the architects of suppression
also serve as the leaders and the
overseers of the process people cease to
believe and it has the requisite effect
which is that people stop trying voter
suppression is incredibly insidious
because it convinces you it's your fault
or it's not worth it and that's why it's
so dangerous because when people cease
to participate in democracy then all
gargy starts to rise and my worry is
that when the very leaders who've been
entrusted with its protection become the
responsible parties for it's not only
dismantling it but for diminishing its
integrity we are all in jeopardy and we
saw that play out in Georgia because
while my election was the big election
where it played out I have a Republican
friend named Dan Gassaway dan and I
agree on almost nothing except we both
live in Georgia he is a hard right
Republican from a North Georgia County
where I think there are 2,500 Democrats
out of like 1520 thousand people he has
had the same election called three
different times because while voter
suppression may target one community its
corrosive effect eventually affects
everyone and they had to redo a
Republican primary three different times
because of the incompetence of the
management of the system and three
different times people who did not live
in his district were permitted to vote
and people who lived in his district
were not allowed the right to vote and
it had to happen so frequently that he
didn't settle we didn't settle a may
twenty eighteen primary until last week
and so while both parties may have some
culpability the intentionality of voter
suppression from the Republican Party is
too glaring to go unchecked and the last
thing I'll say is this when Mitch
McConnell argues that more people
participating in democracy is wrong that
it's a power grab of course it's a power
grab people are trying to grab their
power because it's a democracy that is
deeply problematic and we should be up
in arms that the leader of our Senate
does not believe that the citizens of
America should all be able to have their
voices heard so Stacey the problem
so how are we gonna make sure that so I
things voter registration so in 2014
launched a new Georgia project we have
now registered we started with a goal of
trying to cut into the 800,000
unregistered people color through our
own direct efforts we've already
registered 350,000 people of color and
we've helped stand up other
organizations or support organizations
we should be able to wipe out that
deficit by 2024 that's number one number
two we have started fair fight action
which has filed a massive comprehensive
federal lawsuit that essentially says
it's not sufficient to say that one rule
or two rules are bad we have to call
into question the entire system and
we're using the same theory of the case
that they used in Brown versus the Board
of Education which is that it's not a
question of whether the law says you can
do it if in fact it is happening then
voter suppression is denying the right
to vote and third is fair count which is
the u.s. census program that we're
working on because across the country we
know that the least likely communities
to be counted are children people of
color low-income renters and immigrants
if they are not counted they don't show
up in the census maps they therefore
don't show up in reapportionment maps
they don't receive resources and it's
cyclical if you don't receive any
support from the government and your
life gets worse then you don't trust the
government so you don't participate in
government so you don't get counted by
the government so you don't trust the
government so you don't participate in
the government and that that cycle
becomes self-perpetuating we have to get
more people into the process because you
cannot beat voter suppression with
silence you beat it by overwhelming the
system with your presence and everything
we're doing in Georgia can be replicated
in every state in the country everything
we do is designed for exportation and
replication you can call it whatever you
want we'll tell you how to do it and I
don't need any credit but we have to
have a national engagement of the
urgency of voter suppression and the
erosion of our democracy because it is
happening
time it is happening in a way that is
directly correlated to the demographic
changes in our country and if we do not
halt its corrosion and its speed then we
are going to be locked out of our
democracy in ways that are going to be
untenable in the next decade so you guys
are like half clapping it's ok if you
can clap fully or you can not clap it's
ok either way but there are these air
claps that are really interesting
just to be clear that was not a Jeb Bush
please clap moment okay it was so I want
to try to put this in the context of the
fight were fighting in America today
which is insidious because we have a
president who is playing to the lowest
common denominator of American politics
and therefore trying to find all the
divisive issues the immigration
race generally access sense but it's
playing to this growing sense for those
of you who read hillbilly elegy and
other such descriptions of life today in
America it's obvious that a whole bunch
of folks are angry a whole bunch of
folks are really feeling economically
disenfranchised and what is happening in
my judgment I want you to comment on
this is that a very old tactic is being
RINO specifically I'm drawing from this
book called how democracies die perhaps
the most striking example of rewriting
the rules to lock in an authoritarian
advantage comes from the United States
the end of post-civil war reconstruction
in the 1870s led to the emergence of
authoritarian single-party regimes in
every post Confederate state
single-party rule was not some benign
historical accident rather it was the
product of brazenly anti-democratic
constitutional engineering what we're
seeing today I think is an extension of
the same thing that drove people then
which was the sudden and franchise 'men
of millions of African Americans for the
first time and white South decided how
they're going to fight it and the next
hundred years were defined by that
except that we got a Voting Rights Act
and a Civil Rights Act and some measure
of enforcement but the same strategy in
my judgment is being employed now by a
party that is
shrinking in its base and there they're
doing it I think out of fear and brazen
attempt as they did previously to try to
engineer outcomes so they don't have the
voters you know choose the people they
they choose the voters I forget is that
accurate and if so how do you see that
playing out largely in America as a
whole and what do we then do to mobilize
so that in 2020 that just can't happen
so I think we have to remember that this
didn't just start that what occurred in
Georgia in 2018 has played out in
smaller ways or larger ways across the
country for the last 20 years it's
picked up speed and urgency because of
the erosion of section 5 of the Voting
Rights Act in 2013 with Shelby versus
Holder which essentially said that any
of the constraints on stripping people
of their right to vote were removed but
you're absolutely right that the history
of the south post-reconstruction
african-americans were being elected to
office they were amassing power they
were amassing resources land all of this
halted immediately post-reconstruction
Georgia was the one of the most
egregious states with regards to how
they stripped power because one thing
they created was this county unit system
and that said that in order to win an
election you had to win a certain number
of units per County and every county was
attributed a similar number of units
well as cities grew which were largely
driven by african-american populations
you would have a city like Atlanta that
had 10 times the population as another
County but would have the exact same
voting power which meant that rural
communities which were largely white and
poor were able to overwhelm more diverse
communities whose population did not at
all direct the value of their vote this
may not sound familiar to anyone who's
ever paid attention to the electoral
college
but the other piece of it was that what
what Republicans and it was actually
let's be clear Republicans were actually
the saviors during post reconstruction
they've quickly forgot that by the time
you get the Democrats they were in the
South Democrats were largely Dixiecrats
meaning that we were a single party rule
but it was a very confused party that
contained multitude the civil rights
activists of the 1950s were in the same
party as Bull Connor and and that really
created a confusion about what it meant
to be a Democrat in the South but let's
put that aside what they learned from
the process and what we've seen play out
in the last twenty years is that what
used to be facially racially tinged
things that were intentionally targeted
towards people of a certain race now
have the benign air of universality it's
not that any it's not that black people
can't vote it just so happens that we
have defunded your counties and you
can't don't have the resources to pay
for what you need it's not that Latinos
can't vote it's just that we have
decided that English is the only
language that can be spoken and if you
speak any other language then you really
shouldn't be allowed to read the ballot
even if you're a US citizen it is using
whatever seems seen as facially neutral
standards to impose what are largely
racial and promote ORS on how you limit
access and it is systemic and it is
systemic it began with voter ID because
voter ID there was never a rash of voter
fraud we can't get 50 percent of people
in America to do anything no one is
putting on a wig and a mustache to vote
twice what happened was that across the
country post 2004 people started voting
because they saw that if they voted
things could change and they were angry
enough that they started voting and
suddenly voter IDs came into fashion and
for the first time the Supreme Court in
in 2006 said the voter IDs were okay
that knocked out a whole community of
people including people in the south
many of whom
of a certain age did not have access to
IDs because they don't drive cars they
can't afford it they don't live near
places where it's easy to get an ID and
if you're in Alabama in 2017 they shut
down all the places where you could go
get an ID intentionally to preclude
anyone of color largely African
Americans from getting the IDS they
needed but on its face it was simply we
just think everyone needs to have an
idea it just so happens that this is
directly correlated to income and race
it's the access to the polling places
shutting down polling places on college
campuses because the most likely
Democratic voters tend to be young
people color and suddenly across the
country young people are no longer
allowed to have ease of access to voting
in the state of Georgia you cannot use
your state ID issued by a college as
photo ID to go and vote in Texas you
can't use a student ID but you can use
your gun license
not that that privilege is one group
over the other and so to your point this
has been and it will continue to be a
systemic process because the nation is
changing and there's one party that is
heterogeneous that is intentionally
diverse not necessarily always great at
managing that diversity but at least we
know it exists and there's another party
that is shrinking demographically that
is homogeneous and that recognizes that
the loss of power that is directly
correlated with an increase in diversity
means Adam you nishan and not only power
but in resources and money and in the
ability to impose values when you
recognize that that's what's happening
you start to see every law and every
rule in a different light and that is
that this is very intentional and what
we have to do heading into 2020 is sound
the alarm
that is why everywhere I go no matter
what I do I talk about voter suppression
we have to talk about it as relentlessly
as the lie of voter fraud is spread
because if we do not call it what it is
we will not address it the same way we
have been talking I mean it's taken 20
years to get people to really think
about climate change
as a true emergency we don't we don't
have that kind of time if we want to
save our planet if we want to save our
people we have to acknowledge voter
suppression because the only way power
changes hands is either you rest it
through military means or revolution or
as we do in a democracy you vote out
those who are against your values and
you vote in those who share your values
and what they are doing their best to do
is stop the conversation of values from
being a real one in our body politic so
and just for Breitbart I am NOT
I'm not suborning or encouraging
revolution just I see there a group of
you getting a tan and in the middle
there you guys alright station what is
the impact broadly I want you to reach a
little bit beyond just the voting but
what is what is the current politics
mean for this next election and how
dangerous is what you see now in
American politics to our aspirational
democracy we see examples I mean you
said it very well we see examples of
Thorat Aryan behavior made manifest in
the current occupant of the White House
who has intentionally by passed the
Senate by creating acting secretaries of
almost every major Department who has
tried to use executive authority in ways
that are not only unusual but are
directly contrary to the law and when
he's faced with laws he doesn't like he
blithely ignores them knowing that there
are very few consequences for that
decision we have a codependent Senate
being led by those who are benefiting
from the ineptitude but also the
ignominy of the president and so yes you
get a
but you also get you know the war in
Yemen and so part of responsibility we
have is that we have to reclaim our
international reputation which cannot be
reclaimed until we prove that we are
actually still a democracy and that
means a very robust engagement in the
2020 election not only to change the
leadership and you can vote for a
democratic vote for William weld I don't
I it is most important that we replace
the current occupant with someone who
actually respects the presidency and
respects the integrity of our national
standing and that's what we don't have
and why this is so troubling is that
everything follows from it
there was this week the multilateralism
conference where Germany and Japan and
France are trying to step into the void
left by the United States because we are
no longer seen as legitimate partner and
multilateralism that was a terrifying
reality that the United States of
America is no longer seen as a partner
to most nation states on the key and
core issues that determine our success
as a global community voting in its most
abstract is simply a statement of
principles and if we do not vote and say
that our principles believe that we may
not get everything we want but we at
least want to have a robust debate then
we cease to be who we have stated we are
as Americans for more than two centuries
and why that terrifies me is that things
don't simply stop because America ceases
to participate in the way it should in
fact we know there's an acceleration of
the erosion of global democracy if
you're watching what's happening in
India what's happening the fact that
after Netanyahu's election it was Trump
Pence and Modi who called that's a
question if you look at what's happening
in Indonesia what's happening yes you
know you know better about Bashir and
what happened in Sudan but you've got
dozens of other nation states that
on the brink of both explosions and
population and erosion in democratic
principles that poses a physical harm
and I know that was a larger
conversation but for me the macro
construct is that we stand as an example
of what should be in part because of how
badly we have failed America is an
example of why democracy is important
because we have had to correct ourselves
so many times acknowledging that black
people were actually wholly human
acknowledging that women should be
allowed to be a part of the body politic
making Native Americans citizens moving
away from our very xenophobic
immigration policies over time each of
those moments of Correction standest
signals to the rest of the world that we
can get better not that democracy is
perfect but that we are made more
perfect by each of our Corrections and
when we stop correcting ourselves and
worse when we celebrate our ignominy we
undermine our value as part of a
national an international conversation
do you think there's enough awareness
and energy right now that is focused on
this so that we can actually do we need
to do in the next X number of months I
think in other words do we need to
rekindle the civil rights movement in
America around this issue fundamentally
I think we do and but I think I would
frame it as less a civil rights issue
and more an existential crisis if you
believe in climate change if you think
that you may die because the world is
going to explode if you think that
climate change is real even if you don't
agree with anything else the right to
vote is the only way we will make
climate change policy real if
reproductive choice is your issue the
only way we make reproductive choice
real is the right to vote if your issue
is economic security and whatever your
issue is the right to vote is our only
mechanism and so I don't think it's
recasting this as a core civil rights
conversation in part because people can
exempt themselves from that they're not
bad they didn't do it therefore they
don't have an obligation the right to
vote
is one that when guaranteed for all
guarantees for all and I want us to have
a broader understanding that this is not
simply a construct that is attributable
to how african-americans are harmed
because people find it not easy but
they're there there are many ways in
which if a single community is harmed
you are exempt from participation we
have to recognize that this is the
corrosion across all of our rights it
may target African Americans but it's
going to get us all and so for me the
larger conversation is that we have to
reclaim our democracy if that's your
goal then we have space for more people
to join whether they think that as an
African American I am the direct target
of the harm because if the harm it's
it's the effect of you may a Matt Mimi
but if others are hit by collateral
damage the damage is still real and
therefore we should all be engaged in
the fight which is not you know
certainly as a matter of morality it
should be do it because it's the right
thing to do I come from the body of
politic do it because it helps you to so
let's get it done so if I wasn't here
interrupting your train of thought with
questions sorry
Thrones no no wood and you came out here
this audience was here and you're here
to talk about what you're doing I assume
you would first you would focus on the
problem you describe it then you'd focus
on the macro 40,000 foot here's why we
got to do it but then I assume you would
also get pretty basic into their gut and
say if you want to do this if you want
to do that here are the things this is
why you need to go out and vote what are
those what's your what are you
compelling people to go vote on now and
and that's my point I I don't think I
have to tell you to go vote for the
issue that motivates me I need you to
vote because of what motivates you but
more importantly you need to make space
and create opportunities for others to
go vote so they can do what you want
I find that selfishness is the most
effective means of moving put people in
politics ever it and not in a
narcissistic way but in the
the true notion the selfishness that my
benefit sometimes means I'm going to do
more to make my benefit real therefore
the issues that animate you should be
the reason that you create space for
other people to participate fighting
against voter suppression makes your
possible realities real the continuation
of voter suppression dulls the
likelihood of you getting the change you
need and so one it is not only making
sure you're registered but participating
in the conversation about registration
for others it is not only making sure
that you get counted by the census but
making sure you're participating in
groups that are making sure the census
is made real for others it's finding the
issue that animates you and compelling
the organizations you support to make
certain that their voices are being
heard by ensuring that people can engage
in politics and the reality is if we do
not solve this in 2020
let's be really clear if we do not solve
it in 2020 we are talking about another
four years of crippling erosion if you
thought the last two and a half years
were bad imagine four years and no
consequences it's recognizing that the
urgency of the moment is made incredibly
real because of all of the other issues
that have been hinted at but not acted
on yes we have seen attacks on
transgender communities on immigrants on
black people on women but there are a
lot of other people out there that he
doesn't like and you know he might start
with us first but he's coming for the
rest of us and then the third is that we
deserve better we deserve to preserve
our democracy
and so the action item is make sure
you're registered I mean I assume if
you're sitting in this room you're
registered I'm preaching to an
incredibly loud incredibly large choir
but you all have the ability to then
activate other communities every one of
you touches churches synagogues mosques
community groups that should make this
their intention for the next 18 months
we should not relent on the conversation
of voter suppression because it is a
relentless fight to take out our values
if you doubt it look at the turnout that
we saw across this country in Georgia in
2014 1.1 million people voted for
Democrats 1.25 million voted for
Republicans in this last election 3.8
million people voted 1.9 million
Democrats 1.99 1.9 million Democrats
were allowed to be counted voting 1.9
million plus Republicans with a margin
of 54,000 that is a dramatic increase
and it is a direct result of me spending
18 months telling people that I needed
to hear their voices the answer the call
to action is talk to other people to let
them know their voices matter you have
to ask people to vote do not assume they
will do it because there is word as you
are for a lot of communities they're
worried every day this is just this
another worry you have to connect the
dots and you can connect the dots
through every person you touch every
organization you touch but we have to
believe that if we do not solve it
because when reapportionment happens
when the census happens that's the next
decade of power that's it that's the
ballgame and if people are not counted
they do not count if people are not
heard they are considered to be
acquiescing to what is happening and I
don't believe that's really the case
what's the most important reform that
you think could make a difference States
manage the elections is there a federal
reform that can make the greatest
difference automatic registration or
automatic voter registration solves a
lot of problems
there should be automatic with automatic
upon turning 18 I think automatic
registration if we've said federal law
says you can vote when you're 18
everyone should be automatically
registered they can find your money the
minute you make it they can find you so
so what name are they using if you do
that what name are they using how do you
get away from this name problem there is
no name that's the we've been convinced
that there is somehow this deeply
complicated process that has to be put
in place
India is running an election with 900
million people and they have a federal
law that says you do not have to travel
more than one mile to cast about I
understand what I'm asking you is it's
not that it can't be done or there
aren't any ways to do it it's that you
have these built-in structural
impediments so you yourself have talked
about del Rocio so if if if it's
automatic registration and the
registration doesn't have its belt right
or has a space in it you got a problem
well so I would argue that we do what
they do in California Oregon are the two
states that I think have the most robust
automatic registration they can use your
state ID to register you or they can use
your birth certificate you're going to
always have to have corrections but if
the process begins with the presumption
that you were registered then everything
else is making sure you're doing
correctives to make it real as opposed
to what we have now which is a gauntlet
that you have to run in order to even
get added to the rolls and I presume I
presume you would you would support the
notion that it shouldn't be so hard to
vote because you have to you know you
have to skip work and lose your job or
lose a day's pay we ought to have four
or five weeks you vote and mail in
Jordan Georgian automatic violet
absolutely but that should happen all
across the country to enfranchise people
and that's why I think it has to be
federal law
I think federal law should permit so I
don't just pick one automatic voter
registration there should be mail-in
ballot applicants
Meilin ballot should be permitted
everywhere now I do think that certain
states are going to have more
complicated rules but those rules should
always be we should set a floor for what
happens not a ceiling and the floor
should say automatic registration
multiple ways to access an election
multi week I mean Georgia actually is
really good early voting laws we have
shouldn't we have a standardized
requirement for votes for federal office
for a president United States certainly
under what Dyson what ways what
standardized in what way standard that
that that you you you have a
standardized set of rules by which
people across the country going to vote
for president by virtue of automatic
registration certain amount of time
standard ballot requirements I mean it's
absurd that the ballot can differ place
to place and and be screwed up frankly
by the local by some friendly Secretary
of State right I completely agree I
think and that's my point
I mean what hr1 argues is that we need
to set a federal floor for what is
permitted in the operation of elections
automatic registration same-day
registration which basically allows you
to correct any mistakes that there is
uniformity and how much time there's at
least a limit there's at least a floor
for how much time that can be allowed
now you can decide you want to give
people more time you can decide to give
them more options but you can't give
them fewer options and more importantly
that the federal standard has to be the
standard used for every level of
election within reason so with
registration not necessarily with
execution of an election I don't think
you need six weeks to vote for dog
catcher
but I do think that access to the ballot
registration access should be uniform
and should not be eroded by any state
action and how about national popular
vote electing the president what do you
think of that I I completely grew
it it is misinformation to say that the
electoral college was designed to help
smaller states versus larger states that
wasn't the case it was designed because
we didn't trust non land owning
uneducated people to know enough to cast
a ballot it was once again it was this
notion of the gentry protecting the
serfs although we were a democracy and
it no longer has relevance we should be
able to elect our presidents directly
they lead us we should have a say in how
they lead and who they are
I have no and I co-sponsored the
National popular vote legislation in
Georgia so so what are we gonna do about
Anu as a leader in the house confronted
this every single day the level of
polarization America has never been more
polarized since perhaps the age of
father Coughlin in the 1930s and you
know back around the Civil War period
but pretty hard to get people to talk to
each other we used to be able to come
together a Republican and Democrat we'd
go out to dinner we talk get to know
each other
have a good dinner some senators House
Republicans Democrats alike I remember
going over Ted Kennedy's house and you'd
have Orrin Hatch and John Warner of
Virginia and Mac Mathias and then group
of Democrats and you'd sit around
talking about health care and you go
back to the Senate the next day and get
something done that doesn't happen
anymore they barely work now they come
in on a Monday night or Tuesday they
vote they're there Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday the Senate's become like the
house and they don't do anything so how
are we gonna break this fear people have
of holding their own present and
accountable to things they know are
morally and otherwise wrong but
accountability has disappeared and by
the way when you read any treatise about
how democracies disappear and the
insidious undermining of them there are
plenty of them that have disappeared
over time Hitler came to power in a
democracy he was given power by the
government who thought they were gonna
control him same thing with Shabbos I
mean you can run a list of places where
people came because the governing people
thought oh my god there's this movement
well maybe we can throw Mussolini same
deal folks so you got to look at history
here to understand that when people shy
away from holding people accountable
that's one of the first big undermining
of democracy and that's what's happening
today with the Republican Party that
cares more about president and party and
power than they do about upholding the
Constitution in the United States it's
bad how do we do this so I I've never
been either in real power because I was
in the minority when I was the leader in
the house and I've never been in
Congress but I will say this one of the
reasons I was able to navigate and get
things done even though I was
outnumbered nearly 2 to 1 in the house
was that they needed me when you have to
compromise when you have to negotiate
when what you want requires someone
else's consent or participation your
ideological differences don't disappear
but they become modulated by your desire
for this other thing I think the
elimination of earmarks was the death
knell of compromise and our Congress I
think that earmarks required negotiation
because you would then go home and
they'd be able to show I delivered this
to my community and in the delivery I
had to get along with someone else to
make it so when you no longer have that
incentive for forced negotiation then
what people are judged on now when they
go home is how mean are you to the other
side how intractable are you how much
can you demonize the opposition and
because most of our elections are
decided in primaries there is no
incentive to elect someone not of
moderate views but of moderate process
you don't have to be I am a progressive
but I operate with moderation in my
process meaning I will talk to
and I won't you know call your mama
names in order to get something done I
will actually engage you and in the
process I will learn who you are one of
my someone I knew very closely in the
legislature his name was Bobby Franklin
Bobby hard-right conservative he used to
say the pages of my Bible were missing
because he just didn't understand how I
believed what I believed it was not a
compliment he would introduce at the
beginning of every legislative session a
bill to repeal the right to an abortion
in Georgia I got to know Bobby I would
sit there and talk to him because I
wanted to understand why he believed
what he believed and then the process
means like the dinners you described I
never tried to change Bobby's opinion
about abortion but I understood them and
one day we had an anti-abortion bill
that was based on this false this thing
they were running they were trying
eugenics as an argument that abortions
were bad because they were killing black
babies and therefore they were able to
get a bunch of african-americans to sign
on to the legislation and they were
gonna move it because that was that was
the wrong kind of abortion and it's such
a fallacious argument we don't have to
deal with that piece but i sat with
Bobby and I said look you told me that
you believe fundamentally under your
Christian values that abortion is wrong
on its face and he said yes I said so
how can you vote for a bill that says
this kind of abortion is the only
abortion that's wrong either you think
it's all wrong or you think it's okay
now because I talked to Bobby because I
got to know him we were able to go into
that committee hearing and when the vote
came bobby voted with me and we stopped
the bill and his his allies his
colleagues were stunned because they'd
never bothered to talk to him they
presume they knew what he would do
because of how he'd always behaved and
so part of it is you have to have
incentives and I think earmarks are one
example but the other is that you have
to have humanity which is that you get
to know other people especially those
who don't share your values
we stopped a bill because the staunchest
anti-abortion persons there voted with
me and as he told them it was because I
held him true to his values
now disagreed with him fought him wanted
him to lose but that didn't mean I
couldn't talk to him and get to know him
so we could get good done and that's the
other way I think we can help repair our
politics so how I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
one more question and then we're gonna
turn to you folks and give you a shot
here to get into this dialogue directly
but I but I do want to touch on one
thing before we do that you mentioned it
earlier but I want to get everybody to
really intensely focus on this and
understand the implications the 2020
census will determine congressional
districts for the next 10 years we have
a level of gerrymandering in the United
States today that makes literally it's
impossible for us to have a truly
democratic election in countless
districts across this country and that
is a source of enormous frustration in
many Americans
because you don't get a choice between
the two parties it's decided in a
primary and then there's no genuine
democracy electing the members of the
Congress and unfortunately the Supreme
Court did not do what many of us hoped
it might there are other cases too
bubbling up but the key here is going to
be making sure people accounted and I
would like you really to try to focus in
and emphasize that and and so say what
you've learned from this as a legislator
and otherwise so when I came into the
legislature it was 2006 I came in after
the third lawsuit in Georgia on our maps
so let's be clear gerrymandering is not
the province of Republicans Democrats
did it for decades Democrats didn't
Republicans did it what is different is
how they do it so when I became de
Pompadour so I came in the legislature
no7 I became leader in 2010 so my first
year of leadership was the year of
reapportionment it is a terrible time to
start your
when you're guaranteed to not win we
have 180 seats in the house the
Republicans drew their do themselves a
map the allocated 124 out of 180 seats
this is despite an election that was
determined by fewer than four points so
this was not a 66 you know 34 election
this was a 40 you know 45 55 and yet
they allocated themselves two-thirds of
the house they'd already taken the
Senate in the supermajority part of the
reason they were successful was that
Georgia had a dramatic under count of
almost twenty to thirty percent largely
people of color and therefore when the
lines were drawn even though I knew that
in Douglas County there was a Spurgeon
incandescently push them out of having
any say in their election they knew
where they live they just didn't I
didn't have proof because the census
didn't show them and so what Republicans
did was they packed African American
districts they isolated Latinos and put
them in small pockets so they could
never coalition and then they scattered
Asian Pacific Islanders because they
assumed they would vote Republican so it
wasn't really a big deal and as a result
they were able to give themselves a
supermajority in the Senate and come
close to one in the house if those
populations now what we did in the
following year because I knew where
these people lived was that we actually
were able to claw back four of those
seats and stop a supermajority
because I knew there were black people
in Douglas County I knew there were a
lot of Latinos and Gwinnett who hadn't
been counted I knew that in certain
parts of the state communities of color
had been ignored and I went into those
communities early with teams we did the
work and we were able to get those
populations to vote but that's a lot of
work it was an easier thing to make sure
they get counted in the first place one
because it allows you to have standing
when you're suing against whatever maps
come to fruition if you cannot prove
people exist you have no standing to
argue that they're being disenfranchised
and the only proof point is the census
number two the resources you need in
order to make certain that those
communities are served and therefore
feel like it's necessary to be involved
in the body politic come through the
census if they are ignored in 2020 they
will not get services for a decade if
your schools are overcrowded if they are
under-resourced it is likely because the
children in those communities were not
covered and not counted and thirds
gerrymandering because of the erosion of
the Voting Rights Act the ability to
prove that maps are unlawful the burden
is now so extraordinary as to be almost
impossible to me you have to prove that
someone stood in the well in the General
Assembly and said I hate this group of
people and I'm going to steal their
votes outside of Pennsylvania that
hasn't really happened recently and
therefore you the legal remedies we've
had in years past to actually fix these
maps are nearly gone but let's remember
we still have cases from 2010 that are
pending before the Supreme Court Texas
Wisconsin Pennsylvania we've had some
resolutions but it's taken almost ten
years to fix what was broken a decade
ago we don't have a decade to wait
because if we lose the house if we lose
the House of Representatives and Leydon
and we head into another four years of
the current leadership or possibly worse
then we have no remedy to solve it the
census is our remedy and we have to take
it seriously and that is in every state
everywhere and the last point I'll put
under is this Cal Carol I mean Carol
California I think is spending almost
200 million dollars on their census I
think George is allocated less than a
million dollars California is not 200
times larger than Georgia but Georgia
has no incentive to count the people who
are not being counted and that's why we
started the work we're doing but that
work needs to be done across the south
and across the country so folks we're
going to have a chance to ask you
questions I'm gonna give the first shot
to the former Secretary of Defense this
is an inside job I don't have a clue
what he's going
say no leon panetta you have a mic no
the mics are coming in where mics I know
we had a couple of handheld mics thank
you thank you for your leadership on
fighting for our democracy I appreciate
the work and the sacrifice that you've
engaged in let me let me ask you this
because I recognize that in trying to
deal with registration you've got to go
to every state in all 50 states have
their own rules and it's a it's a hell
of a fight
first of all could you identify those
states that do it right and that are our
model for other states and secondly is
there with artificial intelligence and
all of the other technology that's
developing these days is there a
technological way to deal with this
issue on both registration and voting
sure um I would say that Washington
State Oregon California have all done
very very tremendous jobs on voter
registration rhode island ii think it's
doing really well so on registration
their automatic registration same-day
registration maine has gone back and
forth but they've usually been good
actors when it comes to voting Colorado
has an extraordinary system where they
have incredibly high participation rates
same again I would say what happens in
Oregon is an example and in Washington
state are exemplars of what does what
works well and could be replicated
across the country I think the issue
with expansion of the franchise there's
technology that can make it easier but
we've bought into this narrative that
there was a problem to begin with there
is no problem there is not a rash of
people who are who are scheming to vote
that's not the issue and therefore all
of the solutions to forestall that
non-existent problem have created a
complicated system where no complication
needs exists what we do have to worry
about is the technology that counts the
votes which is why I believe in him are
paper ballots because our systems are
vulnerable
there was a brief spate of time where
people weren't where the technology was
vulnerable but the sophistication wasn't
high enough for there to be the level of
worry but that was probably like two
years but for the last 15 years we have
been in the state of aggressive
vulnerability where our ability to audit
our elections and prove that what people
said is what happened has been
non-existent that is deeply problematic
in Georgia the state buys all of the
machines for everyone so one set of
flaws affect an entire state other
states do it by county but counties have
varying degrees of resources so their
ability to actually fix their equipment
is limited to how well-funded that
County is and that's often based on the
census and so we have to start demanding
sometimes the cheapest solution is the
best paper works I'm gonna stop there so
now that we've got a little bit more
time so there's another question
somebody wants to ask yes yes ma'am yes
right here third row we've got a mic
coming to you just hold on one sec my
name is lorena chambers had the honor to
work with you senator Kerry secretary
Kerry on your campaign but also with
madam leader Abrams was a power-packed
Georgia and we were the independents
been ature down there
we had legal battles on the IE side
consistently with stations for public
and run media folks tearing down our as
I'm happy to say they stayed up because
we had a great legal team and a good
research team and we did great ads on
your behalf I can say I'm feeling
from 2000 2004 2016 and now with your
race I run into folks come saying always
there is no difference between the two
parties in order for us to be able to
motivate this entire room to go out and
legions to work on classes and for
registration I find it in my polling
over and over again we didn't have a we
didn't have any difference in 2016
candidates there is no difference now
what's the reason what's going to change
I know that you we hear this all the
time but I would love to hear from both
of you from so many experiences what it
is that we can use that kernel of
evidence that we can share with others
so that we can motivate many more than
just 50% of the electorate to actually
register and do good work the difference
I know there's a difference but yeah
Stacy good here's the thing people don't
care about your party they care about
their lives and as long as elections are
run based on which party is evil or not
evil it's a pox on both their houses
I believe in talking about the issues
that matter and then using those issues
to say that I am the person and my party
supports these values and therefore this
is why you vote this way but as long as
it begins and ends with partisanship
people aren't going to be invested
because the fifty-first of the people we
need to show up they've never seen
either party do much for them
but they do know what's wrong they do
know what they're missing and what they
want to hear is that you have a solution
and that by engaging the solution will
become real and manifest for them one of
the reasons I didn't concede my election
was that for so long
we have condoned the process we have
condoned the outcome and if you condone
the outcome then you're condoning every
participant in the outcome so part of
the reason for me to say I will
illegally acknowledge the outcome but I
won't concede was that we had to be seen
for all those people who did show up who
broke through that 50 percent barrier
and got up to 60
percent they needed to see that I heard
them and that I didn't suddenly forget
them in order to protect my party or my
political future they needed to see that
I was willing to say you were not given
your choice that you were robbed that
your voice was stolen and that this is
not about me becoming governor this is
about you having your rights heard when
it's about the voter then people show up
once it when it's about the candidate
they can stay home it doesn't really
matter I agree completely with that and
I think we're gonna have to wrap up in a
moment here but let me let me just say
to everybody I don't think that in
reality we have two functional parties
we have loose knit labels and people
fall one side which is sorta to the
right of American politics and people
fall to the other side which is some
variation of left in American politics
and they run under that banner but they
really one run very individually and I
would not spend time talking about party
I spend time talking about what matters
what are the issues around which you
want to organize your life what do you
want for your kids what's what's bugging
you what do you need to have address and
hopefully the people who are running
have the ability to address that now you
know my sense is that this is where I
wanted to sort of wrap it up as we as we
come to the end here particularly to all
the undergrads here and grad students to
all of you currently studying at Yale it
is please remember and it's not an
exaggeration there's no reach in my
saying this to you and the reason I say
there's no reach is because I know what
we did before in 1970 we brought 20
million Americans out of their homes to
organize around the idea that people
didn't want to live next to a toxic
waste site they didn't want to be given
cancer from the Woburn dump they didn't
want to watch the Cuyahoga River light
on fire these were fundamental concepts
Rachel Carson drove our generation to
try to say we want to be able to see
from one end of a city to another and
not
got breathe smog so 20 million Americans
came out but we didn't stop with that we
politically politicized a movement to
make the issue a voting issue and we
targeted the 12 worst votes in the
United States Congress and we went after
them in the 72 election and guess what
seven of the twelve were defeated you
know what happened all the survivors had
their spines stiffened by their survival
and said oh my god this is a voting
issue now and what happened we passed
the Clean Air Act Safe Drinking Water
Act Marine Mammal Protection Coastal
Zone Management we actually created the
Environmental Protection Agency for the
United States of America we didn't have
one until people demanded accountability
accountability that's what you have to
do and if only 31 percent of young
people are voting which means 69 percent
are not we got a problem there's no
question in my mind there is a majority
in this country ready to do the
reasonable things we need to do for the
country but ain't going to happen if you
all aren't the blood and guts of those
efforts because all of what I'm
describing happened because young people
got involved the movement for that
environment it was inspired by Senator
Magnuson but it was affected and carried
out by a young organizer called Denis
Hayes who lives in Seattle Washington
now and still helps with Earth Day
manages Earth Day and we're going to
join I'll give you let you in a little
lead on Monday
I think dr. Ernie Moniz and I are going
to announce a new major global effort to
rekindle this kind of activity so people
will go out and damn it all vote to hold
them accountable if these clowns are
gonna pretend that climate change isn't
happening throw them out
No
democracy does not work unless it is
serviced day-to-day by hard work and
people have just kind of I know the
happier playing video games are happier
going you know I don't know it's crazy
but they'll be the first to complain
that nobody's doing anything about
climate change or the parties aren't
different of course the party is it
different you can find the differences
in a nanosecond so this is what we have
to do and and I cannot tell you how
privileged I feel and excited I am to
have Stacey here talking about what she
is doing everything she has said here
today will not do what it needs to do
unless you all are gonna follow up she
can't do it alone no leader can do what
we need to do now in our country alone
it has to be everybody on deck everybody
engaged nothing more worthwhile so be
the next generation of the peanut butter
and jelly sandwich brigade that went to
New Hampshire and told Lyndon Johnson he
couldn't run for president again that's
what we did the women's movement we came
close to having a Equal Rights Amendment
we made you know great advances towards
that glass ceiling which still needs to
be broken but we're making progress
we've got the civil rights law passed
we've opened up voting more than it's
ever been before not good enough but we
can get there so the bottom line is
Stacey is heroic in what she is doing by
learning and recognizing from a very
bitter experience but turning it in to
something that she's committed to do to
change the country and make the country
was supposed to be and and we're all so
proud of you and we're so grateful to
you for what you're doing thank you for
your leadership keep it up
wait one second hi I
I have one weight about
thank you
I gotta tell you wait wait I have one
thing I want to say am I allowed to do
you are you have my consent
okay I don't know how many of you know
this but but Stacey is a as an author of
romance novels now I have not read I
hate saying I've read them yet button
but I am hoping that this experience
today has convinced her that in her next
novel there is a place for a former
Secretary of State with some gray hair
who deserves to be in your next role I
will make it work
[Applause]
[Music]